welcome back everybody police say a
FedEx driver kidnapped a seven-year-old
girl and killed her and they say that he
confessed to it after being arrested
Tanner Lynn Horner was arrested and
charged with capital murder of a person
under age 10. police in Paradise Texas
which is just outside of Fort Worth say
Athena strand was reported missing on
Wednesday and became the subject of an
amber alert police told the media she
got into an argument with her stepmother
and apparently left the home her
stepmother didn't realize she wasn't in
a room until a while later and then
called 9-1-1 after a huge search
Athena's body was found Days Later 11
miles from her home police found out
that Athena went missing right around
the time that Horner was dropping off a
package for FedEx in front of the house
and authorities say Horner didn't know
the Strand family before this he's in
jail on one and a half million dollars
Bond on Facebook Athena's Grandfather
said that he forgives the alleged killer
posting there's not one ounce of My
Flesh that wants to do this or say this
but but my spirit has heard God's voice
and right now while tears flood my eyes
I declare publicly that I forgive this
man police commented on the strength of
the community during a news conference
this community does not lack losing our
children
and and we could see it because of all
the people who came out and helped us
throughout
this ordeal
it was most meaningful what the citizens
did because we have a close-knit group
of folks here in Wise County
and it's our pleasure to serve these
folks in Wise County the Rangers the FBI
and the Sheriff's Office
we're glad that we've had this
opportunity but we're just sad that it
didn't end the way that we would hope
that it would would end
Terry it's pretty remarkable that the
grandfather says that he forgives the
killer but from a legal perspective do
you think that that statement could
impact the case in any way you know it
actually could I'm surprised to hear
someone say this early in the case that
they forgive the killer you go through a
range of emotions from denial to anger
to sadness but when you make a statement
like that it could ultimately impact a
jury and if that jury heard the
statement and chances are a prospective
juror might hear that statement then it
could affect their deliberations and
this is Texas and this is a death
penalty state and they could very well
spare his life thinking that they don't
want to punish the individual even more
than the family might want to we still
have not heard however from the rest of
the family this is the grandfather
perhaps the parents might feel a little
differently but I do think that kind of
comment could affect the jury at the end
of the day I'll tell you that's not a
comment you hear very often in these
kinds of cases Brian I turned it over to
you what about FedEx could they be on
the hook for damages in a case like this
I mean he was their guy absolutely so my
understanding is that he was a freelance
worker for FedEx but he still went
through the same interview process so
the question becomes what is your
interview process sure you said he had
no criminal record but do you dive
deeper into understanding the people
that you're going to put literally on
other people's doorsteps whether or not
they're going to get sued I think it
would behoove FedEx to re-evaluate how
they interview and how they they hire
people because at least in this
community I don't think they're going to
be trusting FedEx Vans pulling up to
their front yard or their front door
anytime soon something's got to be done
now if there is a problem in their
hiring process either something that
they missed that's already outlined in
their own uh steps that they need to do
or their practices are just out of date
and not that good that other places like
UPS or whatever might find better ways
to interview that could also be a
problem yeah maybe a reevaluation is
necessary in this kind of case